what does job security really mean it
means financial stability waking up and
knowing I can provide for myself and my
family a freelance career can 100
provide that if you build it wisely as
counter-intuitive as it may seem
freelancing may be the best way to build
long-term stability
[Music]
cloud of 10 American workers watching
this will have a freelance career by
2025. that's just two three years out
some of us will perform tasks like
making deliveries or doing remote data
entry and some of us will be writers
graphic designers product Specialists
marketeers software Engineers data
analysts or Business Consultants who are
paid per project and not tied to any one
company having a freelance carrier gives
you the power to get your true market
value and the flexibility to build life
the way you want it but most importantly
it gives you control over your future
making you less reliant on a single
employer hiring Freelancers is good for
organizations too when Freelancers come
on board they come with knowledge from
multiple employers Freelancers also tend
to be more up-to-date on their skills
they constantly read listen and learn
new approaches to remain employable and
Freelancers offer a jolt of energy they
arrive ready to hit the ground running
so how can you be part of this freelance
future here are some steps step one
identify your core value talk to people
your network of current and former
employers and ask them what qualities
make you someone who's worth hiring are
you thorough or fast are you strategic
what types of projects do you really
excel at figure out exactly what value
you bring as a freelancer step two
communicate it to employers once you
know your value you're in great place to
approach potential employers whether
it's places you worked with in the past
or other businesses in the same industry
and say this is what I will do for you
and this is the impact it could have on
your business make your value clear on
your LinkedIn profile and on your
personal website and as to be paid what
you're worth which means you should do
some research on pricing and your value
should translate into your fees step 3
nurture early relationships in the
beginning it's often in your best
interest to take whatever jobs you're
offered it's not all going to be great
or easy but you will learn so much
you'll start to see that you're better
working with Mission driven companies or
with managers who don't beat around the
bush or whether you're happy you're
working remotely or going into an office
working with peers every time you finish
working with a new client ask them for
feedback find out what worked well what
can I do better as a freelancer you need
to be proactive and find ways to improve
it will not only make you better but
help raise your value in the marketplace
step 4 grow your client base over time
as a freelancer your existing customers
are your best references when a project
is about to end ask whether they know
others who might benefit from your
services or ask if they can promote you
and your work in their internal channels
social media platforms or email groups
don't be discouraged it takes time and
consistency to build a stable of clients
put your focus on building a reputation
for good work and you'll eventually have
to turn down more jobs than you can
accept step 5 join a freelance Community
whatever type of freelancer you are find
ways to connect with others in your
field what are the LinkedIn or Facebook
groups to join which events to go to on
which podcasts to listen to this
community will not only help you learn
and give you leads on work but it will
also contain peers that you can vent to
when you need it if you're interested in
freelancing don't wait until you get
fired or laid off to make that leap
remember when you're in rely on one
employer they own your future but by
building your freelance capabilities
you'll have the power to decide not only
who you want to work with but when and
in what capacity and when downturns come
you'll be better able to withstand them
with a network of people who are excited
to work with you
[Music]